- [Interviewer] Where are you from?
- I'm from New York.
But I went to,
we moved from New York and from New York,
we moved to Compton, from
Compton, we moved to Long Beach.
And I went to Long Beach
(indistinct) with my mom.
Like I said, I got two kids,
Mom got three kids, two
girls and three boys.
Single parent, she passed away.
You know, we just cremated her.
I have two kids, I have a boy and a girl.
My sister has none.
My brother have one.
And you know, it was,
this is a normal family.
- [Interviewer] And you're
on your own out here?
- Yeah. I'm not out here on my own.
I got family out here that I grew up,
(yawning)
that I grew up with, so.
I'm here to say that she was cool,
she was cool.
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] So, you're
living on the sidewalk.
- Right now, I'm in a tent
until I can get my apartment
- [Interviewer] What
are you doing for money?
- I got, I'm on SSI, but I sell pussy.
Right, imma keep it real, I sell pussy.
But I'm on SSI, and have my own pay.
And I do, braid hair, and
I do hair for a living.
- [Interviewer] That's what you do?
- Yeah.
And then, and then I used to do porno, so.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you did porno.
So, so I used to do that too.
So that's a lot of money.
I used to do porno.
I stopped doing that,
'cause I had my kids.
- [Interviewer] And,
where are your kids now?
- In New York with my sister.
- [Interviewer] With your sister?
Everybody here is doing
one drug of some sort
- Of some sort, you know,
everybody smoke crack,
everybody do this, everybody do that.
But we all don't bother nobody.
We running our own business.
We all take care of each
other and we all get along.
We all, from the Mexicans
to the Blacks, to the Asians
to the Chinese, we all get along.
My dad is Asian, so it makes
me a little Asian too, so.
Yeah, his name is Lee Taylor.
He's mixed, he's Asian.
So, out here, we just all, a big family.
- [Interviewer] When
did your mom pass away?
- She been gone a long time ago.
Like, after I had my
daughter, she was around.
Then, after I had my son,
she was still around.
So, she just, a long, long time ago.
We don't put her in the wall.
- [Interviewer] What age
were you when you left home?
- I was 17.
- [Interviewer] 17, and you came where?
- Down here, and then I came
back and went back home,
and when I came back home, I was pregnant.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] How many
years you've been on Skid Row?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] How many
years you've been on Skid Row?
- Since I was 17.
That's like seven years, going on.
(indistinct) though.
I've been down since I was 17.
- [Interviewer] What do you do for food?
I go to Michigan, I sell pussy,
or I go, I do whatever I gotta do to eat.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I have a fiance.
He goes there also,
and he do whatever he gotta
do for us to survive, so.
- [Interviewer] What you'd
like to see happen for you
in next five years?
- [Candace] I would love
to see me and my fiance
and my happy kids in a nice little house.
- [Interviewer] Sounds good.
What's the craziest story
you've seen out here?
- [Candace] I saw a lot
of people get killed.
I saw my best friend dragged,
get dragged down the street.
- [Interviewer] Dragged
down by what, a car?
- [Candace] In a car.
Yeah, my best friend, China.
I have saw her get literally down,
dragged down the street.
Adult dealers dragged her down the street,
and I saw it with my own eyes.
(indistinct)
- [Interviewer] She was
attached to the car?
- [Candace] Yeah, she was under the car.
She was, she was, the guy, the guy dra-
It was a lady.
She went to the lady,
I guess, the lady grabbed her money back
and grabbed the dope
and dragged her down the street
and killed her.
Yeah.
And then my best friend, my other homeboy,
he got killed in his tent.
He got killed.
He came out of his tent.
There was, the police
and him was fighting,
and he, the police shot him seven times,
one in the head and one in the chest.
He didn't die in his tent,
he died behind his tent.
Then my other homeboy, he
died in his tent, by the car.
And that's it.
(interviewer chuckling)
- [Interviewer] That's a lot.
(car engine sounds)
- [Interviewer] How was your Mother's day
- I didn't work out.
What I really wanna do is see my kids
and I didn't get to see 'em.
- [Interviewer] How'd
you get the black eye?
- How I got the black
eye? I got into a fight.
- [Interviewer] With who?
With a dude.
Women like me do not
need to get in no fights.
Specially with nobody.
- [Interviewer] You got
in a fight over what?
- Over stupid stuff, stupid stuff.
(interviewer chuckling)
- Seriously.
We, okay, we might smoke,
we might have fun, we might do this,
we might do that,
but still a woman should
not get hit by no man.
- [Interviewer] Definitely.
So, I tell you, I've been through hell,
I've been throughout.
You know, I can't, I can't complain.
I see these people down there every day.
Tired. I'm tired.
I wish I could change.
Like I said, I wish I could
change stuff, but I can't.
I go to school.
I'm a good parent.
Can nobody say nothing bad about me,
and I help people every day.
I try to.
Like I said, I've been
down here since I was 17.
I wish I could change the
world, but I, I won't-
(chuckling) It ain't gonna
be easy, but, you know.
- [Interviewer] Tell me what
it's like when you pick up
some strange guy on the street.
- Man, let me tell you about that.
Oh, now that, now that, I can tell you!
Okay, I've been stabbed in the stomach.
- [Interviewer] You've been
stabbed in the stomach?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] By one of these guys?
I was six months pregnant.
- [Interviewer] Six months
pregnant and you got stabbed?
- Uh-huh.
I had got raped,
(indistinct)
my mouth covered up,
and all that.
- [Interviewer] Guys
got police to back up?
- Yeah.
Like I said, I saw my
best friend get stabbed.
I saw my best friend get
dragged down the street.
- [Interviewer] You told me about that.
- You know.
My homeboy got killed
in his tent by a cop.
- [Interviewer] So you got
stabbed six months pregnant.
What happened?
- I was bleeding in the inside.
But my daughter came, my daughter,
thank God she was alive.
I didn't have a tour, but they had
to stitch me up, 'cause
I was stabbed real bad.
- [Interviewer] You delivered
right then and there?
- I delivered right then and there.
And not in an hospital either.
I delivered on the streets.
- [Interviewer] You kidding?
- No. In a hotel.
My homeboy doped me up, put
dope on the inside of me
then hit the pipe,
and I had
a early labor.
I didn't feel no pain.
(sighing)
I didn't feel nothing.
I looked down and my
daughter was on the floor.
- [Interviewer] And she's okay?
- Yeah. She's eight years old, today.
Well, now, she's eight years old.
And I look at these women
now that they's pregnant.
Why would y'all going to
be down here, pregnant?
You know what I mean?
I have stories.
I've been through it,
and I, now I see what I went through.
I don't wanna sit here and
watch other people do it.
Boyfriends beating them up,
while they pregnant?
You know what I mean?
My homegirl got kicked and
stomped in the stomach.
Right, somebody,
cause she didn't want to
do what he told her to do.
Stomped her in the stomach
and her baby fell out.
One hand missing,
one eye,
one nose,
in four, in three minutes,
and half of her head.
- [Interviewer] The baby?
- The baby. It is a formed baby
inside the toilet, in the park.
They had to park- to close the park down
until they got that
baby out of the toilet.
- [Interviewer] Baby in the toilet?
- The baby fell inside the toilet.
It was a,
an all baby.
But the eyes missing, nose,
something's wrong with the face,
something's wrong with the ears,
something's wrong with the hands.
Fingers, feet.
Huh?
- [Interviewer] It was deformed.
- Deformed, yeah.
- Hands, feet missing.
So, you tell me how it is downtown?
Ain't nothing out here,
for people to be out here.
(loud truck noises)